ja liebe zuschauer jetzt hat man es
schwarz auf weiß viele corona maßnahmen
hatten kaum wirkung es ist die korona
klatsche für team vorsicht also für karl
lauterbach und co der expertenrat der
bundesregierung rechnet jetzt mit den
pandemie regeln naja das 18 köpfige
expertengremium das sollte erklären wie
wirksam die maßnahmen gegen die pandemie
waren damit bund und länder jetzt im
kommenden herbst nicht alle fehler
gleich nochmal machen und jetzt jetzt
wird das papier 165 seiten hat hier
gleich sie sehen das bild öffentlich
vorgestellt wir wissen schon was
drinsteht blog downs haben nur im
anfangsstadium einer pandemie eine
starke wirkung so die experten und
länger der lockdown umso schwerer dann
die schäden und auch die wirkungen der
schulschließungen sehen die experten
kritisch wenn wir direkt mal rein in die
pressekonferenz die jetzt startet
bei einander
es hat ordentlich krach gegeben haben
zwischen den experten zwischen dem team
vorsicht und denen die versuchen die
lebensrealität realität vieler menschen
ein bisschen mehr abzubilden in den chor
ohne regeln jetzt im sommer man merkt
dass vielleicht jetzt auch im privaten
umfeld irgendwie man das gefühl es
steigt schon wieder alles so ein
bisschen an dann macht sich jetzt da
aber gerade rechnet frage an die technik
dort die die dort die experten
hoffentlich mit jahr läuft beantworten
können damit wir gleich seine inhalte
reinhören können denn es wird spannend
es wird wegweisend dafür sein was uns
alle im herbst im winter dann erwartet
wie wird unser leben dort aus
unterstütze diese experten raten rät die
bundesregierung um maßnahmen abzuleiten
in der korona pandemie
und wenn wir hier nicht gesehen und
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach denn ich an dieser
pressekonferenz teilnehmen wird der sich
das ganze aber hoffentlich dann auch zu
herzen nehmen wird sehr geehrte
vertreterinnen und vertreter der medien
ich heiße sie im saal hier und online
herzlich willkommen zu dieser
pressekonferenz auf der der bericht des
sachverständigenausschusses zur
evaluation der rechtsgrundlagen und
maßnahmen der pandemie politik in
deutschland vorgestellt wird wir sind
heute an einem eher ungewöhnlichen ort
für einen solchen pressetermin
normalerweise würde er in den
räumlichkeiten der bundespressekonferenz
stattfinden aus terminlichen und
logistischen gründen musste der termin
heute allerdings hier am wzb stattfinden
ich möchte noch kurz darauf hinweisen
dass aus gesundheitlichen gründen der
vorsitzende der kommission
herr professor stefan huster heute
leider nicht teilnehmen kann an seiner
stelle begrüße ich die stellvertretenden
vorsitzenden frau professorin helga
riebsamen chef und frau professorin
andrea kießling die uns aus frankfurt
zugeschaltet ist ich begrüße außerdem
hier im saal die kommissionsmitglieder
frau professorin jutta allmendinger zu
meiner rechten herrn professor christoph
schmidt zu meiner linken und herrn
professor hendrik strich ebenfalls zu
meiner rechten
bevor wir starten ein paar kurze
hinweise ich bitte die kolleginnen und
kollegen die online per zoom
zugeschaltet sind zu überprüfen ob ihr
klarname und das medium das sie
vertreten in ihrem zügen fenster
angezeigt wird falls nichts bitte ändern
sie die angaben entsprechend und ich
hoffe sie haben verständnis dass ich
nachher umfrage teil nur diejenigen
aufrufen kann deren klarnamen lesbar ist
vielen dank bitte achten sie auch darauf
dass ihr ton jetzt ausgeschaltet ist
die anwesenden und zugeschalteten
kommissionsmitglieder werden im ersten
teil dieser konferenz einen überblick
über die arbeit und die ergebnisse der
kommission geben sie orientieren sich
dabei im wesentlichen an der struktur
des berichts der ihn vorliegt danach ab
zirka 12.30 gehen wir zum frage teil
über und die pressekonferenz endet dann
um 13 uhr jetzt übergebe ich das wort an
frau ob sein chef britische ja vielen
dank auch von meiner seite ein
herzliches willkommen und an herrn
professor schuster den ich hier als
vorsitzenden der kommission vertreter an
dieser stelle nochmal alle guten wünsche
für baldige genesung wir sind ja im
september letzten jahres aufgefordert
worden oder gebeten worden gemäß § 5
absatz neuen infektionsschutzgesetz die
regelungen und deren auswirkungen zu
evaluieren und dabei geht es um diverse
maßnahmen die nach dem ausbruch der
pandemie mit dem ziel eingeführt wurden
die überlastung des gesundheitswesens zu
vermeiden und die gesundheit der
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen zu
schützen mehr als zwei jahre nach dem
beginn der pandemie soll der vorliegende
bericht nun entsprechend antworten auf
diese fragen geben die ansprüche an die
kommission und an den bericht sind hoch
ziel ist es einen wesentlichen beitrag
dazu zu leisten entscheidungsträgerinnen
und entscheidungsträger in politik und
verwaltung eine informierte solide
grundlage für zukünftige entscheidungen
und maßnahmen und strategien zu gehen
also gerade keine abrechnung mit politik
wie man bereits lesen konnte es geht
also ganz klar darum den auftrag zu
erfüllen
mit dem vorliegenden daten die da sind
und man muss sagen dass die erfüllung
dieses auftrags dadurch erheblich
erschwert wurde dass wir eben zu
bewertung erst zwei jahre nach beginn
der maßnahmen aufgefordert worden sind
und dass es fern auch nicht gelang seit
dem beginn der pandemie eine
ausreichende stringente und begleitende
datenerhebung zu etablieren und mit
diesen einschränkungen muss die
kommission aber auch die gesellschaft
umgehen hinweisen möchte ich noch darauf
dass die kommission auch empfehlung zu
themen ausgesprochen hat die nicht
zentraler bestandteil unseres auftrags
waren die uns aber essentiell wichtig
erschienen zum beispiel zur
kommunikation in krisensituationen und
auch möchte ich festhalten dass in der
knappen zeit es leider nicht möglich war
auch empfehlungen zu maßnahmen der
pandemien bekämpfung hinsichtlich
impfstoffe und diagnostika und
medikamente abzugeben die natürlich auch
sehr wichtig wären
bevor wir nun durch die empfehlungen
gehen lassen sie mich noch mal betonen
dass es von großer bedeutung ist zu
unterscheiden in welcher phase der
pandemie maßnahmen ergriffen werden und
was ihr ziel ist am anfang wird man
versuchen die ausbreitung eines erregers
lokal zu begrenzen containment phase
nennt man das und gelingt es nicht geht
man die phase über wobei die folgen
versucht zu vermeiden und das ist dann
die sogenannte mitigation phase ich
glaube dass das immer sehr wichtig ist
sich diese diese bewegung innerhalb der
pandemie und die veränderungen der ziele
vor augen zu halten wir werden nun im
einzelnen zusammenfassung zu den
kapiteln geben und ich darf professor
schmidt bieten die ergebnisse zu den
grundlagen der evaluation und dem
datenmanagement zusammenzufassen vielen
dank
dann übernehme ich gerne nahtlos es war
uns von anfang an klar es wird so anfang
im herbst des vergangenen jahres
zusammen getreten sind den umfassenden
bestand an wissenschaftlichen durch
begutachtungsprozess geprüften einzel
belegen für
die wirksamkeit die nebenwirkungen und
kosten einzelner maßnahmen oder gar mast
von maßnahmen bündeln die man als
wissenschaftler nur noch mehr nach den
etablierten regeln der kunst nur noch in
anführungsstrichen zusammenführen muss
diesen bestand gibt es nicht es gibt
viele einzelbelege es gibt viel evidenz
gibt viel literatur aber es ist nicht so
dass wir einfach die bestehenden körper
an evidenz zusammenführen können und
haben unsere aufgabe erledigt warum gibt
es die nicht nun das liegt am
zusammenspiel von wissenschaft und
politik also insbesondere muss eine muss
die politik in einer krise wenn sie sich
nachher prüfen lassen will wissen gutes
vorhaben ist ein sehr sehr gute gute
absicht dann muss die politik schritt
halten bereits oder bereits zu beginn
die voraussetzungen dafür schaffen nur
dann kann es eine schritt halten und
retrospektive evaluation im vollen
umfang geben das heißt also die konzepte
müssen stimmen von anfang an muss man
sich fragen was sind die fragen die wir
nachher beantwortet wissen wollen die
daten müssen bereitgestellt werden in
einer art und weise erhoben werden in
einer art und weise die diese
beantwortung nachher ermöglicht bundes
muss schritt halten und auch die
begrenzte wirkmächtigkeit staatlichen
handelns klar kommuniziert werden denn
wofür braucht man eine evaluation naja
um zu sehen was funktioniert und was
nicht funktionieren das haben wir
gewusst aber darauf zu warten bis dieser
bestand erarbeitet wird
also je größer die flughöhe der frage
umfassender die fragestellung desto
weniger wird das als nebenprodukt des
krisen handelns verfügbar werden das
muss wie gesagt gestaltet werden darauf
zu warten bedeutet man käme für
politisches handeln zu spät also die
wissenschaft muss auch pragmatisch genug
sein antworten auch zu geben die im
perfekt sind die auch in perfekter
datenlage auch beruhen und nach besten
wissen und gewissen den stand der dinge
zusammenzufassen immer mit dem blick auf
die vorläufigkeit und genau das haben
wir uns vorgenommen haben evidence
gesammelt nach bestem wissen und
gewissen und nach intensiver diskussion
bewertet eingeordnet und bewusst dabei
die multi disziplin arid unseres tuns
genutzt wir sind zu sehen einen schritt
zurückgetreten das ist mehr der
methodische teil und haben uns gefragt
was sind denn eigentlich in einer
solchen situation die richtigen fragen
wie stellt man die richtigen fragen wie
kann man sie im prinzip beantworten in
einer so komplexen situation dass viele
dinge einander überlagern zusammen
irgendwie in einem paket nur wirken
nicht isoliert betrachtet werden können
das haben wir an den anfang gestellt und
wir haben aus juristischer sicht
diskutiert ganz im gleichen
pragmatischen sinne wie das bisherige
vorgehen einzuordnen ist und welche
vorschläge für weiteres vorgehen
auszuarbeiten sind es ist also keine
generalabrechnung mit dem bisherigen so
nach dem motto jetzt sagen wir mal was
sache ist und dann sind wir fertig
sondern es ist eher ein neuanfang eines
noch besser fundierten diskurses darf
ich kurz die ergebnisse von kapitel 3
und 4 oder die die schlacht
schlaglichter auf kapitel 3 und kapitel
vier sätzen kapitel 3
widmet sich nicht zuletzt der frage was
ist denn eigentlich die richtige frage
wie kann man überhaupt an die richtige
frage danach stellen was staatliches
handeln auslöst was ist denn eigentlich
die gegen situation ist die eine
situation mit weniger staatlichen
handelns mit anderen staatlichen
handelns mit überhaupt keinen
staatlichen eingriffen das klingt alles
viel einfacher als es in der praktischen
umsetzung ist um dann ein studiendesign
zu verwenden dass diese fragen zumindest
mal näherungsweise erlaubt zu stellen
ineffiziente und unwirksame maßnahmen
enttarnt und wirksamer als solche
identifiziert braucht man statistische
begleit daten umfassend und
schritthalten ausgewertet man muss die
qualität staatlichen handelns zu dem
auch nicht quantitativ
überprüfen und quantitative statistische
analysen durchführen dass das möglich
ist solche großen pakete so zu behandeln
dass haben wir bei den hartz-reformen
beispielsweise gesehen und wie frau rief
sein chef ist schon andeutete es ist
jetzt nicht zu spät das ist zwar spät
aber es ist nicht zu spät noch mehr an
einem übergreifenden konzept für public
health epidemiologie klinische forschung
zu arbeiten dafür braucht es kapitel 4
daten die datengrundlage und das
datenmanagement sind nicht teil unserer
aufgabe oder unseres auftrags
ursprünglich gewesen wir sehen es eben
aus den
der nannten geschilderten umständen
heraus als zwingend an dass wir uns auch
damit beschäftigen es gibt einen großen
bestand an daten was will man eigentlich
von den daten was erwartet man nun zum
einen möchte man dass endemische
potenzial schritthalten begleiten man
möchte die schwere profile sehen die
ressourcen belastungen versuchen zu
verstehen um politisches handeln darauf
auszurichten und dafür gibt es viel die
meldedaten des ifs gehen die gemeldeten
testergebnisse die überlegung der
intensivstationen allein die verknüpfung
die datenbereitstellung verknüpfung die
erhebung und das verfügbar machen sind
keine selbstläufer da müsste noch mehr
geschehen was hat man gemacht in der
krise man hat sich sehr auf modell
gestütztes auf ex ante simulationen also
modellierung verlassen das ist ein
wichtiges tool aber worüber wir
insbesondere in unserer kommission ist
ja die rückwärts gefahren direkt respekt
nicht rückwärtsgewandt im sinne von
altbacken sondern die retrospektive
bewertung was ist tatsächlich dabei
rausgekommen nicht was kommt vermutlich
dabei raus wenn menschen sich so
verhalten wie wir es vermuten in einer
ex ante simulation es gibt vieles was
wir optimieren können die
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
erfordert eine entsprechende
infrastrukturelle initiative datenschutz
und datensicherheit probleme sind zu
lösen ein wichtiger punkt ist mut zur
stichprobe von erhebungen zu haben die
spät kommen oder uns ständig fehlerhafte
im endeffekt erhoben werden ist
vielleicht nicht so hilfreich für
politisches handeln wie auf
repräsentativen stichproben und
geeigneten aus diesen ermittelten
indikatoren zu arbeiten da wären wir der
meinung da könnte man sehr viel oder
sollte man sehr viel mehr machen
insbesondere auch ressourcen belastungen
personalfragen et cetera im
gesundheitswesen mit erheben auf
kleinräumiger ebene und das in plattform
für multidisziplinäre forschung zur
verfügung stellen danke
dann darf ich weitermachen zunächst
einmal freue ich mich sehr über ihr
interesse
ich freue mich auch sehr dass ich die
ehre hatte in dieser kommission
mitzuarbeiten die tolle kommission war
was auch immer man schreibt sie über
toll und ich glaube sagt wenn ich jetzt
über risikokommunikation spreche dass
ich eine mitverantwortliche für dieses
kapitel bin aber in dieser stelle ganz
herzlich
herrn professor rosenbrock größen möchte
der leider auch an corona erkrankt ist
warum haben wir uns mit der
risikokommunikation beschäftigt genauso
wie mit daten und modellen ist das eine
der zentralen präventiven ansätze die
wir jetzt richtig aufstellen müssen um
den nächsten pandemien und anderen
krisen davon hab mir im moment wahrlich
viele sachgerecht zielgerichtet vor und
hingegen stehen zu können und wenn ich
das sage so weil die risikokommunikation
einen zentral wichtigen baustein
darstellt um vertrauen in die
wissenschaft überhaupt zu generieren und
das wissen über wissenschaft vertrauen
in die politik aber auch das vertrauen
was das zusammenleben der gesellschaft
mit uns und über uns betrifft das ist
genauso wichtig wie eine wichtige säule
der wissenschaftskommunikation der
risikokommunikation ist dass man die
menschen überhaupt erstmal in die lage
versetzt bewusste entscheidungen zu
treffen was also arbeiten wir in diesem
kapitel heraus zunächst mal es ist
wichtig dass wir schnell informieren es
ist wichtig dass wir informieren auch
mit dem risiko auf dass wir immer
hinweisen müssen dass ja die
nachrichtenlage dass das was wir wissen
sich auch verändern kann dass wir also
in einer woche was ganz anderes sagen
müssen weil wir mehr wissen als jetzt
also die veränderbarkeit des wissens wir
müssen viel transparenter und mit
besseren maßzahlen arbeiten die grafisch
darstellen mit einer leichten sprache
wir müssen sie den bevölkerungsgruppen
gehen aufsuchen die wir allzu leicht
vergessen in unserer kommunikation im
allgemeinen aber gerade auch in zeiten
von krisen pandemien wir brauchen einen
partizipativen ansatz keinen von oben
nach unten weil wir wissen dass das die
menschen heute nicht mehr mitnimmt und
wir müssen tatsächlich auch ehrlich sein
wir müssen darstellen was für chancen
bestimmte maßnahmen haben aber auch was
für risiken bestimmte maßnahmen haben
das gehört zu einem diskurs dazu genauso
wie zu einem diskurs dazu gehört dass
wir abweichende meinungen sehr sehr
ernst nehmen
wenn wir das machen dann heißt das dass
viele organisationen zusammenarbeiten
müssen und was meine ich mit vielen
organisationen
das sind natürlich die krankenkassen die
da mehr hätten tun können es sind
natürlich die sportvereine die oft viel
näher an den menschen dran sind sie sind
die gewerkschaften arbeitgeber
vertretungen wir müssen da viel stärke
in den jeweiligen man sagt ja oft zu
schulden blasen in denen die menschen
sind rein kommen und wissen zu den
menschen bringen und nicht warten bis
sie irgendwie zu uns geflogen kommen an
die türe klopfen und sagen wie war da
setzt das ist das was ich dazu zu sagen
habe wir haben es voran gestellt weil es
in der tat eines der dinge ist die wir
sofort anzupacken haben im sinne einer
guten public health initiative so wie
sie auch im koalitionsvertrag schon
dargelegt ist
ja vielen dank ich möchte mich generell
einmal erst mal bedanken vor allem bei
der für die konstruktive mitarbeit
zusammenarbeit im team bei der
geschäftsstelle die mit in die nacht
mitgearbeitet hat am ende und vor allem
auch dem wzb die jetzt quasi unsere
pressestelle übernommen haben weil wir
haben gar keine pressestelle und in
kürzester zeit hier quasi eine große
pressekonferenz organisiert hat was uns
übrigens auch ermöglicht hat eine
fristgerechte abgabe zu haben gestern
was er schmidt festgestellt hat trifft
natürlich am deutlichsten auf die
getroffenen maßnahmen zu wir haben keine
contra praktische realität wir haben
eine schlechte datenlage es gibt über
200.000 publikationen zu 119 und weniger
haben aber den evidenz grad die man sich
eigentlich wünschen würde für so eine
evolution idealerweise würde man auch
ein systematisches revier durchführen
dass es aber in dieser form eigentlich
nicht machbar
das kapitel ist daher so aufgebaut dass
wir erst mal den erhofften effekt
beschreiben dann die intendierten
wirkung also die evidenz für die
intendierten wirkung dann die evidenz
für die un- intendierten wirkung also
quasi die nebenwirkung wenn man das so
beschreiben würde und die daraus
abgeleiteten handlungsempfehlungen
wir haben uns folgenden themen gewidmet
einmal den lock down und den lockdown
maßnahmen als maßnahmenbündel die
öffnung nach 2g und 3g regeln kontakt
nachverfolgung quarantäne isolation test
und schulschließung wir haben uns nicht
den impfungen gewidmet wir haben hier
die ständige impfkommission die konstant
und gewissenhaft dauerhaft eine
bewertung durchführt und das wollten wir
auch in der hand der stiko lassen und
auch eine gegenüberstellung von zum
beispiel schließungen von
kulturveranstaltungen
sportveranstaltungen im vergleich zur
schließung von restaurants werden sie
nicht im bericht finden werden da das
alles maßnahmenbündel gleichzeitig
fahren das können wir einfach nicht
bewerten wir legen auch keine tabelle
vor was richtig oder falsch ist wir
sagen auch nicht dass es gut dass es
schlecht sondern wir versuchen diesen
graubereich denen es da einfach gibt in
der evaluation auszuleuchten und damit
in der zukunft und auch für zukünftige
wellen entscheidungsträger die
möglichkeit haben eine noch informierte
abwägung zu zu erhaben auf
die verschiedenen phasen der pandemie
ist für rücknahmen schiff bereits
eingegangen das will ich jetzt nicht
noch mal darauf eingehen aber man muss
auch bedenken dass bei den maßnahmen bei
unterschiedlichen phasen der pandemie
auch unterschiedliche die eine
unterschiedliche wirksamkeit haben und
auch ein unterschiedliches ziel
verfolgen das werden sie auch im bericht
jeweils finden wenn wir jetzt einmal
kurz einsteigen ich kann das nur
umreißen zb in die frage nach den lock
downs im grunde sind das wie eben schon
mal angedeutet maßnahmenbündel wir
können die nicht mehr auseinander
rechnen ist unmögliches wurde alles
gleichzeitig ergriffen man kann das zwar
ein modellierung machen aber jedes
modell hat eben auch seine probleme und
wir können auch schon schlecht
ländervergleiche machen da jedes land
auch mit einer anderen lok down kultur
reagiert und wir haben deswegen in
diesem bereich nur relativ und
modellbasiertes wissen aber es gibt hier
ein großes aber das möchte ich jetzt
auch mal deutlicher hervor stellen es
gibt eine biologische und physikalische
plausibilität vor und es gibt keinen
zweifel dass wenn wir unsere kontakte
reduzieren dass wir auch die ansteckung
wahrscheinlich keiten reduzieren so ist
das einfach weil das weil das virus sich
eben von mensch zu mensch übertragen
wird und gerade zu beginn einer pandemie
ist es sinnvoll die übertragung in der
bevölkerung so weit es geht zu
reduzieren und dem gesundheitssystem den
spielraum zu geben um sich zu wappnen
für die anzahl an infektionen
also wäre wenn erst wenige menschen
infiziert sind hat es einen besonderen
effekt aber lockt downs wirken eben auch
nur wenn der mensch mit macht je länger
ein lockdown der dauert und je weniger
menschen bereit sind die massnahmen
mitzutragen das haben einige studien
gezeigt desto geringer ist der effekt
und umso mehr schwerer werden eben auch
die unerwünschten wirkungen
auf deutschland wäre das im übrigen die
erste welle also die phase des
containments von den integrierten
wirkung können sie nachlesen da gibt es
viele eben auch im gesundheitsbereich
das können wir an dieser stelle kann ich
das aber nicht umreißen
öffnungen nach 2g 3g regel auch hier
können wir keine klare effekt größere
benennen da eben auch hier
maßnahmenbündel gleichzeitig ergriffen
wurden aber auch hier stellt sich eben
noch mal mehr die komplexität einer
evaluation dar da wir nicht nur zu
unterschiedlichen zeitpunkten
unterschiedliche varianten hatten und
dadurch auch unterschiedliche impfstoff
wirkung hatten und wir einen ganz klaren
zeit effekt dann noch mit drin haben
aber wenn du jetzt nach vorne schauen
und jetzt nach und sony krohn speziell
anschauen dann wissen wir das ist ein
effekt geben muss in den ersten zwei
drei wochen für die für eine zweig regel
nach impfungen und nach genesung aber
dieser effekt sehr schnell vermischt und
dann nicht mehr vorhanden ist auch der
erhoffte effekt das sekundäre effekt
eines matchings also des anstoßes dass
man sich impfen das kann eigentlich in
den studien nicht abgelesen werden in
allen ländern in denen es
zugangsbeschränkungen gegeben hat für
nur geimpfte hat es nicht den erhofften
geweckt gegeben dass die menschen sich
mehr haben impfen lassen
also wenn man in zukunft über
zugangsbeschränkungen nachdenken sollte
aus der politik ist in anbetracht der
leichte übertragbarkeit der derzeitigen
impfstoffe eigentlich nur mitnehmen mit
einem tagesaktuellen test im moment zu
arbeiten ich überspringe die
kontaktpersonen nachverfolgung auf
kunden derzeit aber wir noch einmal auf
die masten eingehen masken wirken das
muss man deutlich sagen das wissen aus
epidemiologischen und erkenntnissen
tierexperimentelle und bestätigungen
zeigen einfach das masken eine wirkung
haben daher können masken auch ein
wirksames instrument in der pandemie
gekämpft sein aber es gibt leider
deutliche unterschiede zwischen der
evidenz des effekts des mastens aus
kontrollierten studien und den effekt in
der praxis es wird deutlich dass eine
schlecht sitzende und nicht angepasste
maske kein einen verminderten bis keinen
effekt hat was im grunde darauf
hinausläuft dass der maskenträger auch
die maske tragen will weil ansonsten hat
die maske auch keinen effekt
und der effekt einer maske ist eben vor
allem dann darin hoch prävalenz gebieten
wo prävalenz bedingungen nicht mehr
niedrig präferenzen vorhanden sind
hier wird eben auch deutlich mal wieder
die kommunikation deswegen hat frau
einem dinge dass herr vorgestellt und
wir äußern uns auch nicht zur ffp zwei
masken dass da sie im moment nicht den
effekt der auch hofft wird aus den
evidenzen sondern da ist es einmal mehr
stärker so dass wenn die maske getragen
richtig getragen wird hat sie einen
starken effekt aber nicht eben in der
praxis bisher ableitbar da sollte sich
eine gesonderte kommission einmal mit
beschäftigen zu schulschließungen ganz
zum schluss ein sehr emotionales thema
für viele und es gibt zahlreiche
stellungnahmen dazu auf die wir auch
alle hinweisen aber aufgrund der
wichtigkeit des themas
können wir das nicht in voller gänze
beurteilen in deutschland waren im
internationalen vergleich waren die
schulen um 38 wochen geschlossen und
liegt damit im vergleich im mittelfeld
auch hier kann der genaue effekt von
schulschließungen nicht aus den daten
einfach abgelesen werden auch an schulen
gab es maßnahmenbündel auch in der zeit
gab es maßnahmenbündel und auch hier
greift eben sich die frage nach der
biologischen physikalischen
plausibilität zusätzlich erschwerend
kommt der unterschied dass bei
unterschiedlichen varianten kinder und
erwachsene sich unterschiedlich stark
infizieren bei omikron sehen wir zum
beispiel diesen unterschied den wir am
anfang in der bälle gesehen haben in der
infektiosität bei kindern sehen wir bei
omikron eigentlich eine ähnliche
infektiosität von kindern und
erwachsenen
daher kann hier auch nicht abschließend
von der evidenz auch wenn sie plausibel
ist nicht die effekt größe definiert
werden und ich übergebe hier eine frau
einen dinger für die unzensierten
wirkung
hier kommen die sozialwissenschaftlerin
ins spiel und ich möchte mal diese
nebenwirkungen in drei große felder
unterteilen die ersten zwei unternehme
ich und mit der wirtschaft schließt
natürlich unser wirtschafts experte
christoph schmidt ab es geht um die
individuellen folgen zunächst einmal wir
haben hier starke evidenzen überhaupt
gar keine frage was schulschließungen
machen mit kindern aber mit den kindern
sind ja auch immer die eltern verbunden
shoppen in einem kapitel dargestellt wie
stark die psychischen auswirkungen sind
wir stark die physischen auswirkungen
sind und darunter verstehen wir
natürlich so etwas wie die zunahme von
als die zunahme von depressionen die
zunahme von einsamkeit gefühlen die
zunahme auch von gewicht beispielsweise
für kinder das ist international sehr
gut belegt auch wenn wir auch hier
darauf hinzuweisen haben es ist nicht
nur die schulschließung als solche
sondern es das miteinander des ganzen
geflechts von maßnahmen und wir können
im moment nicht sagen es ist dieses was
kausal dazu beiträgt
es gibt natürlich auch kognitive folgen
wie ist eigentlich der lernerfolg wie
ist der laden fortschritt wir wissen aus
studien mittlerweile dass kinder die
leistungsstärker sind auch in zeiten von
schulschließungen viel mehr zeit zu
hause verwendet haben auch die besseren
materialien hatten aber die besseren
digitalen endgeräte hatten als kinder
die lounge schwächer waren und
wesentlich weniger zeit aufgebracht
haben das ist eine ihn bekannte studie
des ifo-instituts die wir hier
rezipieren wir haben aber für
deutschland noch keine daten die zeigen
wie langanhaltend beispielsweise
kompetenzverluste sind ob sie wieder
wettgemacht werden können über die zeit
und
ob sie das können hängt natürlich auch
von unseren intervenierenden variablen
ab also davon ob wir jetzt gerade mit
den betroffenen schülerinnen und schüler
mit den lernschwächeren kindern die auch
noch aus niedrigen sozialen ökonomischen
schichten kommen uns besonders
beschäftigten und alles daran setzen
diese schulschließungen und viele dieser
digitalen unterrichtsformen
nachträglich so gut es irgendwie geht zu
kompensieren was ist also diesbezüglich
zu tun wir brauchen auf alle fälle hier
eine viel größere individuelle
erreichbarkeit die kann auch digital
sein wir brauchen digital coaches die
die kinder daran führen in hilfe an die
hand geben und nicht nur den kindern
sondern natürlich auch ihren eltern wir
brauchen aber auch und das steht sehr
deutlich darin so etwas wie ein
rechtsanspruch auf ein mindestmaß an
sozialen kontakten der ja auch oft
verloren gegangen ist auch und gerade zu
bezugspersonen
wir müssen hier einfach auch zu
ungewöhnlichen maßnahmen greift mein
lieblingsbeispiel ist immer dass wir
hier abschlussklausuren im größten
ballsaal berlins durchgeführt haben man
hätte mit den schulklassen auch in
museen gehen können in kirchen gehen
können wo wir mehr platz gehabt hätten
also was wäre in thinking out of the box
und das halten wir für absolut notwendig
wenn ich auf die gesellschaft jetzt ein
gehe dann haben wir zwei bereiche
untergliedert einmal der ganz besonders
betroffene bereich von eltern mit
kleinen kindern und hier nochmal genauer
von müttern kleiner kinder die da die
kinder keine infrastruktur mehr hatten
die kitas waren oft zu oder waren was
die quarantäne dann der kinder betrifft
nicht zuverlässig offen weil ich wieder
zu hause bleiben mussten bei den schulen
ist es eben so und wir sehen bei müttern
in der tat ein ganzes bündel von
negativen auswirkungen die zufriedenheit
tritt dramatisch nach unten
es reduziert sich die arbeitszeit die
bezahlte arbeitszeit
wohingegen die gezahlte gesamte arbeit
nach oben geht einfach weil sie
unbezahlte betreuungszeit so viel
stärker nach oben gehen wir sehen ein
rückfall in alte geschlechterrollen
welche sie als tradition ali sierung
bezeichnet habe und wir sehen ein
unglaubliches ausmaß an mentaler
erschöpfung
auch hier sind wir sehr klar in dem was
wir zu tun haben wir brauchen
zielgruppenspezifische ansprache wir
brauchen eine entlastung von
insbesondere jungen eltern und wir
können das ein recht das haben andere
länder zum teil auch vorgemacht die
zweite große gruppe über die wir
sprechen ist nicht minder wichtig das
sind die sogenannten bullen arabien
kommen also arbeitsmigranten personen
die arm sind in armut leben oder von
armut gefährdet sind und die müssen wir
viel mehr erreichen weil wir schon
während der pandemie sehen was wir jetzt
noch verstärkt durch die inflation sehen
und durch den krieg und den
energienotstand dass die schere aufgeht
zwischen jenen die sich irgendwie
behelfen können die kontakte haben und
jenen die sich eben nicht mehr helfen
können und unsere hilfe brauchen und
auch das können sie entsprechend
nachlesen der dritte block ist dann die
wirtschaft und das macht herr schmidt
ja sehr gerne mache ich auch ganz
schnell es gibt ja einschlägige arbeiten
des sachverständigenrats der
wissenschaftlichen beiräte von
finanzwirtschaft also wird also die
große abrechnung des
expertengremiums 18-köpfige ja zu den
crooner maßen was ist eigentlich alles
schiefgelaufen was lief falsch wir
wollen das ganze analysieren mit unserem
bild politik chef jan schäfer jan war es
denn wirklich jetzt die große abrechnung
also je länger diese pressekonferenz die
wir gerade gesehen haben gedauert hat
umso größer war eigentlich das was du
jetzt gerade als abrechnung beschreibt
in der tat und ganz spannend war gerade
was professor allmendinger gesagt hat
zum thema schulyok da und ein thema was
ja wahnsinnig viele mütter und väter
umgetrieben hat auch großeltern in
dieser zeit die rede war von 38 wochen
geschlossener schulen hier in
deutschland 38 wochen das muss man sich
mal vorstellen dass es fast ein gesamtes
schuljahr dass die schulen hier
geschlossen waren und das was professor
anwender gerade formuliert hat hat
eigentlich echte sprengkraft muss auch
wegweisend sein für das was bei
künftigen pandemien dann die regierungen
verordnen sollten sie hat einen
rechtsanspruch gefordert auf sozia auf
ein mindestmaß an sozialen kontakten was
nicht mehr bedeutet als dass sie gesagt
hat wenn es mal wieder eine pandemie
geben sollte
muss es auch die möglichkeit geben für
schülerinnen und schüler immer soziale
kontakte zu haben rauszukommen von zu
hause und sie hat gesagt warum ist man
nicht in museen gegangen beispielsweise
da verteilt sich ja auch die luft sehr
sehr gut warum ist man nicht in
kirchengang beispielsweise hat die
besucher also warum hat man und ich
formuliere jetzt extra drastisch die
kinder eigentlich über 38 wochen
weggesperrt ohne irgendwie nach zu
schauen und zu gucken und zu überlegen
was macht das eigentlich mit denen in
psychischer sind inzwischen sind ich
finde das war als würde er gerade
gesehen haben wirklich klartext ich
glaube das berührt das herz auch von
ganz vielen eltern die durch diese
pandemie durchgegangen sein dass kinder
ganz konkret auch um die mütter auch da
ganz klar benannt was mit den müttern
gemacht wurde während der pandemie was
die folgen jetzt sind sie jetzt
gesprochen von einem unglaublichen
ausmaß an mentaler erschöpfung richtig
dass es in der tat so wenn man sich die
statistiken anschaut dann waren auch
viele väter berufstätig zu hause im
home-office aber mutmaßlich noch mehr
mütter die viele dinge geschultert haben
und für zwei kinder drei kinder
vielleicht sogar vier kinder hatte
natürlich in diesen 38 wochen
geschlossene schulen extrem viel zu tun
neben dem eigenen beruf noch die
betreuung der kinder und die wenigsten
hatten oder haben auch das geld um
soetwas auszulagern zu sagen wir haben
ein privatlehrer engagiert oder eine
studentin die sich dann darum gekümmert
hat also massive belastung auch richtig
und das kann man auch wenn es jetzt sehr
vornehm vorgetragen wurde schon als
echte harte sehr sehr scharfe kritik an
den corona maßnahmen der regierung der
regierung oder aber auch der
landesregierung muss man sagen
beschreiben diese ganzen spätfolge
wirkung die wir hier sehen diese
erschöpfungszustände aber auch
deutlicher anstieg von depressionen bei
den heimkindern angstzuständen also
alles mütter ich würde die väter da
nicht ganz aus nehmen aber vor allem
auch die kinder das sind die
langzeitwirkung und die experten auch
professor strikt hat es gemacht
kritisieren ja das eigentlich in diesen
corona runden immer nur auf den status
quo geschaut wurde immer nur geschaut
wurde war können wir jetzt aktuell
verhindern damit sich das virus nicht
weiter ausbreitet aber nie eigentlich
groß darüber nachgedacht wurde was sind
eigentlich die langen folgewirkung
dessen was wir gerade tun aber ja das
ist ja auch schön und gut das ist jetzt
gesehen wird wir sind ja auch alle davon
betroffen gewesen
schön dass es jetzt auch endlich mal
jemand so sieht wie wir schon lange
sehen aber wer steht jetzt dafür ein der
zieht konsequenzen wer entschuldigt sich
vielleicht auch die bundesregierung die
das jahr zu verantworten hat massgeblich
besteht zur hälfte nicht mehr es gibt
ein neuer bundeskanzlerin die eine
hälfte der bundesregierung ist jetzt an
der macht stellt dem bundeskanzler das
ist die spd die cdu ist abgewählt in der
opposition und grüne die zum teil an
landesregierungen beteiligt waren sind
jetzt mit in der regierung die fdp auch
an landesregierung mit beteiligt ist
jetzt auch teil der bundesregierung also
alle sind irgendwie ein bisschen mit
bitte mehr oder weniger muss man sagen
mit beteiligt gewesen karl lauterbach
kann für sich immer noch reklamiere ja
ich war ja nicht gesundheitsminister
aber er ist ohnehin derjenige der ja
eigentlich diese verschärften maßnahmen
immer gut oder die scharfen maßnahmen
immer gut gefunden hat
wenn du mich fragst gehe ich nicht davon
aus dass irgendjemand daraus
konsequenzen ziehen wird man muss allen
politikern jetzt mal zu gute halten es
gab bisher keinen masterplan für diese
pandemie das ist richtig was man auf
jeden fall aber kritisieren muss ist das
eigentlich gerade bei der
bundeskanzlerin immer die gleiche runde
an experten saß es fehlten die
kinderärzte beispielsweise es fehlten
auch ökonomisch finden die psychologen
es waren meistens physiker biologen
epidemiologen die dann auch modelliert
haben aber es fehlten viele viele
berufsgruppen oder ärzte experten aus
anderen bereichen die unser tägliches
leben aber auch tangieren die war nieder
auch auf druck medialen druck nie
eingeladen und das ist das was man
glaube ich deutlich vorwerfen muss was
man auch im nachklapp jetzt ganz klar so
formulieren muss dass das nie wieder
passiert wir müssen in solchen runden
die bevölkerungsgruppen viel viel
stärker abbilden psychologen zum
beispiel wären toll gewesen um genau zu
sagen achtung wenn ihr die und die
maßnahme macht könnt ihr das machen ihr
müsst muss wissen die folgen werden so
und so verheerend sein und das ist das
was gefehlt hat und deswegen ist das was
heute hier vorgetragen wird auch sehr
sehr wichtig für den weiteren fortgang
nicht nur bei dieser panne sondern auch
bei allen anderen die vielleicht noch
kommen werden es ist wirklich wegweisend
man kann doch eigentlich jetzt erst
resümee jan der gar nicht so jetzt in
den herbst winter gehen und sich jetzt
noch einmal wagen schulschließungen der
bundesweit anzuordnen jetzt im moment
sowieso gesetzmäßig gar nicht möglich
sondern nur vom bundesland hotspot und
so weiter aber man kann doch eigentlich
ausschließen dass man auf basis dieser
erkenntnisse jetzt die alten fehler so
drastisch wiederholen kann wir haben
gelernt dass man eigentlich gar nichts
mehr ausschließen deswegen würde ich das
auch nicht machen aber ich glaube es ist
richtig zu sagen auf basis dessen was
jetzt auch gerade vorgetragen wurde und
was die experten
herausgefunden haben obwohl die auch
immer wieder sagen wir können nur ein
maßnahmenbündel bewerten wir können
nicht einzelne maßnahmen bewerten aber
bündel und nehmen wahr dass schul bündel
aus masken pflicht aus einem sehr sehr
langen lockdown und aus sozialer
isolation verglichen auch mit werten
dass man sagt dass kinder eigentlich nie
die großen ansteckung treiber gewesen
sind vor diesem hintergrund würde ich
dir auf jeden fall zustimmen dass das
nicht wieder passiert aber wir haben es
in den vergangenen jahren ja immer
wieder erlebt es kam immer wieder
überraschungen obwohl man glaubte es
soll kein doktor mehr geben gab es dann
doch ein und obwohl es hieß der wird gar
nicht so langsam wurde er doch immer
wieder verlängert deswegen würde ich das
nicht ausschließen faktum ist aber und
das hast du gerade gesagt es ist sehr
sehr es gibt sehr sehr viele viele
deutliche folgewirkung negativer art aus
diesen langen schulschließungen deswegen
wäre wahrscheinlich jeder minister der
das zu verantworten hat gut beraten ist
nichts zu tun hoffen wir alle dass das
wirkliche wirkung hat was dort eben
gesagt wurde besten dankt herrn schäfer
für deine anderen diese danke